[Musique]
dans cette ruelle d'une grande artère
des bennes à déchets bien remplie et des
bacs de recyclage à temps de leur
cueillette
mais derrière ce restaurant il n'y a
presque rien ce n'est pas un hasard ce
restaurant est un établissement zéro
déchet rien ou presque ne doit finir à
la poubelle on se demande un peu comment
on pouvait faire un changement puis
faire quelque chose de différent puis
aussi faire quelque chose qui est plus
proche de nos valeurs
le resto pub la cale c'est le vaisseau
de quatre corps sert de la cuisine qui
ont décidé de réduire leur empreinte
environnementale au minimum contre vents
et marées ils se sont engagés à suivre
les règles du zéro déchet comme refuser
réduire mais aussi fabriquer beaucoup de
choses sur place excellent os qui va
avoir l'énergie qui doit être mise on
fait un autre piano no pain no no good
old chap leur et terreur les tortillas
et c'est rare on trouve postule un vrac
nous parle fait tout ce qui est
habituellement emballé dans les petits
paquets 10 ou quoi que ce soit avec un
fournisseur conventionnelles dont le
phénomème fait qu'on évite les déchets à
la cale dans l'optique zéro déchet en
fait tous nos jeux et nous commençons
donc par exemple en ce moment c'est le
temps de la canneberge donc on fait un
un jus maison puis on fait des grosses
quantités quand c'est le moment de la
saison pour conserver tout au long de
l'année je ferai pas jamais deux voilà
ici parce que c'est vraiment sur
emballés par contre si je fais une
grosse quantité de saucisses sur place
je vais aller chercher une grosse
quantité dans un sac ça fait un déchet
elle vient prêts seront faits les
sociétés
le zéro déchet s'applique aussi dans la
salle à manger comme avec ces serviettes
de table ici à la main le poney papier
parchemin et dans nos paniers de fruits
les choses sont faciles à éviter qu'il
faut juste mettre en place ça ne fait
pas du lavage
mais je trouve que ça vaut la peine pour
le long terme
même le mobilier est fait maison en mode
récupération le baril si le comptoir
seagate avec des solives de planches etc
et sont des résidus d du chantier de
construction ici mais je doute planer
avec mon grand père bernard pied avec
josh hill uqam et associés au débat qui
est la baule et tables c10 bois de
palettes riscle et toutes ces
adaptations peuvent sembler un vrai
casse tête mais selon le chef il suffit
de réfléchir dès la conception du
restaurant s'est instauré des modes de
fonctionnement qui sont claires pour les
employés puis pour l'équipe qui une fois
que c'est clair c'est vraiment pas si
compliqué que c'est une fois que la
machine est parti ça se fait un peu tout
seul dans le fond
par exemple avec de lui délivrer par un
camion citerne nos réservoirs c'est plus
écologique parce que nous les avons une
durée de vie de 20 ans contrairement aux
gens qu'ils crème des 16 litres quincey
et après tu jettes puissants sorts aux
risques ajoutant dans les déchets qu'on
se déplace vraiment quand les clients
leurs besoins
l'équipage du restaurant a su s'entourer
de fournisseurs qui partage leurs
valeurs comme ces producteurs de pouce
on s'est mis le but de développer des
outils qui minimisait l'impact des
humains sur leur environnement
on ne demandait que ça paie le modèle
ultra locales comme on appelle on se
déplace en mode à peu près moins de 20
km en moyenne à peu près 10 km des
tables de production sont zéro déchet
parce que c'est très difficile de zéro
zéro déchet on essaie d'être un des
dossiers ont le plus possible on essaie
de minimiser le plus possible on vient
chercher un plateau par exemple dont
vise que la plus grand le plus grand
défaut c'est mieux que de viser 100 % ne
rien faire et nous demandent de pommade
d'emballage paquet pour moi c'est encore
plus facile on recueille on essaie de
récupérer les classements comme ceux
pour les amène
e
seuls quelques restaurants au québec
disent viser le zéro déchet la chaîne
saint-hubert elle s'en approche
80% de ses rôties three compost les
déchets de table pour détourner de
l'enfouissement plus de 3000 tonnes de
matières organiques chaque année
mais tout comme la cale l'entreprise
doit payer pour ce service de compostage
en fait une municipalité n'ont
l'obligation desservir leur secteur
résidentiel seulement mais pas le
secteur commercial donc il demande aux
entreprises de s'organiser eux-mêmes
quelques villes avant gardistes comme
levi et drummondville ont toutefois pris
les devants pour répondre aux objectifs
probation on doit atteindre au moins 60%
de détournement de la matière organique
donc ceci est un incitatif alors les
certaines municipalités qui ont été vers
leur secteur commercial pour améliorer
leurs performances augmenter leur tout
détournement
[Musique]
au bout de tous ces efforts on obtient
bien peu de choses en fait voici la
semaine la seule poubelle à la cale
canovas a pris six mois avant que la fin
donc voilà ça c'est un déchet qu on
évite pas vraiment et malheureusement
deux kilos et fromage en grains c'est le
plus gros forme ok moi je connais
maintenant depuis qu'on a réouvert après
la pandémie ne certains déchets qui
existe qui n'existait pas avant l'on
n'est plus au taux de 3 à 6 semaines
pour un sac bel de format moyen
[Musique]